uh so you point out that there are uh
extremists on both sides but that the
vast majority of the violence comes from
people associated with the alt-right i
think the percentage was something
around 80 or four to one
uh
which
i think most people sense uh that that
uh that there's a higher propensity for
instigation and violence uh from
the right and you you do paint a picture
about what a civil war
could
look like in the united states which
would not be a civil war in a
conventional sense where you have
political
uh entities and conventional warfare but
instead you have dozens or hundreds of
militias engaging in what most people
would consider terrorist activities uh
how many militias are there right now in
the u.s i think there's over 400 um
so we we were at a peak previously in
1996
and that's the year that timothy mcfay
bombed the federal building in oklahoma
city
militias had been growing
prior to that and then they declined
after oklahoma city and they declined
because the fbi was quite uh effective
at going after these groups and um
and imprisoning their leaders and
infiltrating them but also in part
because i think american the american
public was so disgusted by what they saw
that if these these far-right groups had
or these militias had a hard time
recruiting that shifted in 2008 since
2008 we've seen once again um the rise
and a rapid rise of militias most of
it's been
on the far right uh the vast majority or
i think about 65
of those far-right groups are white
supremacist groups about 25 or
anti-federal government groups there's
some overlap between the two but that's
what we're seeing on the far right
now i get a lot of emails from people
saying well what about the far left and
what about antifa
you know is you know are you being
biased by only showcasing the right
um and
my response to that is you know there's
great data on militias
and we actually know that
far left
militias were the majority in the in the
60s and 70s so you could think about the
black panthers you could think about
um
violent environmentalist groups
anarchists um so it was the left
in previous decades that was
that was dominant
they have been declining um and the far
right has been growing to the point
where um you know most of the the
violent extremists here in the united
states are definitely on on the far
right antifa exists um
uh but it's it's one group it's it's
small and and again in terms of of
numbers the numbers of of militias on
the far right is much greater
so you paint a daunting picture uh
people are now picking up on it
in the mainstream and we all owe you a
debt uh when you started your book you
didn't know that events would then end
up essentially verifying
uh your thesis
uh
so you do suggest some solutions so one
of the facts in your book that really
struck me
uh is that of the civil
wars that occurred in democracies over a
multi-decade period
uh none of them were in proportional
democracies they were all in
majoritarian
uh or presidential systems
which the us has
and
you
present and i think this is correct is
that look people may go through the
political system unless they feel like
there's just no hope for them
and
i'm not sure if you you know but i i've
started
uh the forward party to try to shift us
towards a more
dynamic representative uh
multi-multi-party
uh democracy which i i think is a must
uh what solutions
uh do you think are most vital for us to
try and make progress on
uh
in the time we have because i you know
people also know that i'm very i think
trump runs again in 24 i think he wins
the republican nomination i think he uh
he is a very very strong bet to win
outright um or if he doesn't win
outright
say he won and then uh you know we'll
see
a replay of january 6 but on a larger
scale
um so i i suppose i just doubled down on
the very you know dark picture that you
painted in your book
um so
what are the things that you are most
animated about in terms of solutions it
sounds like one of them is social media
for sure well that would be the easiest
solution
you know we the us government regulates
all sorts of industries that we know
could potentially harm american citizens
we regulate the meat industry we
regulate
mainstream media television and radio
so we understand um how powerful
a tool media can be and how it could be
used um to really tear societies apart
and and yet here we have this enormous
um
uh
media vehicle that is is now dominating
everything else it's bigger than any
traditional media vehicle it's where
most people are getting their news and
there's no regulation
and i actually am not
somebody who advocates censoring um what
people put on uh social media platforms
i think people
for the most part should be allowed to
put whatever they want on these
platforms free speech go for it what i
what i don't believe should be allowed
is for social media companies to take
again the the most divisive the most
extreme the most um
you know incendiary material and give it
an enormous audience instantaneously and
mag and basically be a megaphone
for that information because they know
that that information keeps people
engaged and keeps them coming back more
than information that would be helpful
to society and um so the fact that that
that they're allowed to do this and and
that there there's no restrictions and
we're and we're now in 2022 seeing you
know many of of the negative effects
there's all of these trends that have
emerged um since around you know the
late 2000s since you know 2010 the
decline of liberal democracy the rise of
ethnic nationalism the rise
of of hate crimes the rise of of um
far-right
extremist groups
the rise of militias like all of these
things are happening at this particular
moment in time and you have to ask
yourself
like
what is causing it and why is it
happening now what has changed to make
this possible and and
you know
everybody keeps gravitating back too yes
it's social media and and you know the
fact that
that there there are no regulations on
this despite these really awful outcomes
is really um shocking it would be at the
five biggest tech companies are here in
the united states um it would be easy
for us to to tamp down this this
negative uh bullhorn
well it'd be easy of us if our
government was
not
decades behind uh uh the
technological understanding curve uh you
know uh i mean right now even when they
do have hearings on it they berate the
tech leaders about uh issues that strike
me as marketing i mean like that like
like like the central problem is that
they're profiting to the tune of
billions of dollars by an algorithm that
uh accelerates hatefulness uh anger fear
resentment and oh by the way it's
uniquely subject to foreign
misinformation yes it's it's the
backdoor way
that our enemies can undercut our own
society it's you know they can't take on
the us military um you know it's hard to
infiltrate the united states in other
ways but boy it's really easy via the
internet via social media now you also
recommend i agree with this i agree with
just about everything you you uh
prescribe
um that our government has to do better
at delivering benefits to various folks
and you you suggest things like
maybe healthcare
maybe
maybe something that they know
um that that uh you know is a win for
them um i like cash that's one of my
preferred mediums um and you you
describe this as out bidding which i
found to be a really interesting frame
it was like a political science term um
but that when
people are incited to violence uh
there's like a a bid for their loyalty
from
extremist groups uh or from ethnic
entrepreneurs or whatever and and and
you suggest look the government can
outbid
these other groups yeah um yeah so
you know we didn't have an ethnic
faction in this country
really until
recently
you know america didn't have racially
based parties um as late as 2008 white
americans were equally likely to vote
for democrats as they were to vote for
republicans
but that changed when barack obama came
to power and that's when the white
working class
and that group had traditionally been
supporters of the democratic party and
they supported the democratic party
because the democrats the social and the
economic policies
were more aligned with working-class
interests than the republican party's
policies
and they began to gravitate towards the
republican party because the republican
party was offering other things um they
were
they were using cultural issues they
were
um playing on on you know fears of of
you know changing demographics so they
were offering other things to the white
working class and then the question is
okay why were they able to do this and i
think one of the answers is
um that both the republican party but
but the democratic party um
also um they
in some ways didn't protect the white
working class from the negative effects
of globalization you know bill clinton
signed nafta
brooklyn signed nafta that that
you know on average
helped um uh you know americans but they
were losers in in the in nafta here in
the united states and that was you know
mostly white working class men who who
used to have good union jobs
that you know allowed them to lead um
solid middle-class lives
and when those manufacturing jobs left
um you know the democrats didn't put in
place
um you know a safety net to help that
group um and in fact the you know the
both parties have been
have been you know reducing social
services over time
to
middle class working class
and poor americans
and and so there are real grievances out
there
but when you think of the sons of the
soil
and these are this is groups that had
once
been dominant politically and
economically these are these are groups
who who enjoyed lots of privileges um
who who are then seeing that their
status
is declining relative to other groups i
think i think that's what happened they
or on an absolute scale because you know
their life expectancy is diminishing you
know that's not relative that's uh yeah
and you know their their divorce rates
are increasing you know they're they're
less likely to own homes and there's a
whole series of social indicators where
they have declined and latinos and
um and
african-americans for example um you
know at worst they've remained steady
and so that that is you know building
resentment you know why are we doing why
are we doing worse when in fact we
should be doing better than everybody
and and that's where that you know this
this deep sort of anger and resentment
comes from
[Music]
you